trusting growth has a program and they  take all the top managers to italy  amber pack your bags  what you're going to italy  i have a feeling you're going to fall in  love okay i was kind of thinking that  too  [Music]  welcome everyone i would like to  introduce our ceo nick martucci ciao i  meet you  he's my assistant cat  i'm excited to get to know you a little  better  get dressed  [Music]  what roles do love and affection play in  your life where is this going  i'm really happy you're here amber  i can't afford this it's next week  [Music]  okay  i'm a repository for nikki's dirty  secrets  you seem so open-minded  why does everyone keep telling me that  [Music]  listen i think something weird might be  going on  look guys  nick's in the study working what is this  clue he's killing colonel mustard with  the lead pipe  [Music]  [Music]  this program sucks  lighten up a little bit please  [Music]  you